-(ZIPPER ZIPS)
-MR. PEANUTBUTTER:
I know what's been going on.
Ah! I wasn't gonna pee.
I was just taking my penis out.
You've been driving me around,
but there was something else
happening the whole time.
Uh... What are you
talking about?
You weren't just working
as my driver, Todd.
You were becoming my friend.
Oh, yeah. That was happening.
Well, I could use a friend
right about now.
There's something I really
gotta get off my chest,
and if it got out, it could
destroy the whole wedding.
No, I'm not great
with sensitive information.
I don't know if I'm ready
to get married again.
Don't get me wrong.
I love Diane so much.
I didn't have any doubts
until I realized she had doubts.
Then I figured
she's smarter than I am.
Maybe she knows things I don't.
You are kind of unloading a lot
sensitive information here.
The last thing I want to do
is hurt Diane,
but I keep having this dream
where she's gone.
There's no break-up, no tragedy.
She's just gone, and my life
continues without her.
Hey, thanks for listening
to all this.
You're a really good friend,
Todd.
(GROANS)
Since you weren't able
to give me any useful intel,
I had to offer up my restaurant,
but now, we're on my turf.
-Time for operation "I don't."
-Yeah, sounds good.
You know, with my knack
for coming up with plans
and your ability
to hear them
without contributing
more than three words at a time,
we make a pretty good team,
don't we, Todd?
-You said it.
-See?
♪ (NEWS THEME PLAYING)
MALE REPORTER: Beloved character
actress Margo Martindale
is in police custody tonight
for her role
in a failed bank robbery.
Margo Martindale?
But first, pizza for breakfast?
The answer might surprise you.
I know her, but how?
Wait.
She was at the convenience store
the night I bought
that video game
and ruined my rock opera.
TODD:
She's the one who asked me
to hand her that tape
from the 10¢ bin.
(GASPS)
That means Margo Martindale
likes tapes!
And a tape is something
you listen to,
but tape is also a sticky thing
you can use to seal boxes.
Boxes is what cereal comes in.
What does it all mean?
Am I just grasping at straws?
Wait. Straws... that's it.
Straws are used
to drink soda or water,
and plants need water.
And BoJack used Margo Martindale
as a plant at the bank
and the convenience store,
which means-- Ugh!
BoJack hired Margo Martindale
to make me find that video game
so he could kill my rock opera!
Aw, dude.